what's your i'm going to ask you to put
your money where your mouth is now
having read a fair bit of
evolutionary psychology what's your
feelings on what would have been a
typical ancestral setup
for um relationships yeah so
i mean basically what i've read um for
you know what goes on in hunter-gatherer
societies
um they were largely monogamous
for the most part uh for multiple
reasons
um one reason is um it was essentially
impossible to stockpile resources
uh in a hunter-gatherer forging society
so
uh a man could not accumulate vast
amounts of material wealth
simply because if you're in a a small
band or a tribe
and you're constantly moving you know
going where the food is where the water
is you can't
hoard like lots of material resources
and carry it around with you
um that's one reason and then another is
that simply
um you know men had to rely on one
another and trust one another
in war and in hunting and
you know men aren't going to go you know
fight for
you know their someone in their in their
tribe who has all of the women
right like why would they do that and so
basically men had to
essentially i mean the sounds you know
maybe doesn't sound so good but
basically like
men had to create a system where the
sort of
access to sexual partners or whatever
was roughly equal
in order for the tribe to survive um
now this doesn't mean that in
hunter-gatherer societies
you know infidelity didn't exist or
you know me poaching which is you know
luring someone else out of a
relationship like
there's there's research on modern day
hunter gather societies and
there is infidelity there is you know
cheating
there's you know divorce exists
in a way where basically like you know
people will switch partners later on and
leave their current partner
so there's there's all the things you
know all these things that are sort of
recognizably
um parts of human nature
but you know polygamy
and its variations didn't appear to
exist
until the the rise of agriculture um
once people were able to sit in one
place and
and stockpile resources the invention of
money uh the ability to have
you know uh to command large armies and
so on
um those things didn't come until after
the advent of agriculture but in in
small bands
um they were mostly monogamous as my
understanding but
you know the question often the question
is you know are we naturally monogamous
are we naturally promiscuous what are we
um and the answer is we're kind of both
there is no
you know universal template for human
beings
um it looks like in terms of stability
monogamy is the best um both you know
maybe modern society and also in
in forging societies um but
you know people still do have urges and
people
want to you know have have more than one
partner
divorce is widespread and so yeah we
sort of
want to what does it have our cake and
eat it too yeah yeah
which is very you know that's very human
[Music]